ragazzi avete presente quel gioco dove
c'è la panza dei fori e ti devi tirare
le rocce in bocca ecco finalmente ho
provato a giocarlo con una persona
perché giocava da solo ti chiedi un po
cosa stai facendo della tua vita in
gatto si è proposto di farmi da
avversario quindi buona visione
ecco ci aspetta ha funzionato non fa
niente da pina york dai minimo di
tutorial mi scusi ma lei non ha mai
giocato niente è no allora aspetti che
le spiego aspetti ok allora lei sia via
ecco esatto lei prende con f i sassi e
politiche che marcia si è bene che le fa
vedere dove lo lancia ma gli aggravi
mente ma pounds io mi aspettavo d'elba
mano perché poi riesco dal sasso io e
perché i responsi a con i sassi
rimanenti non mi chieda il motivo ma
interessante su questo c'è un altro modo
da incidere che hanno anche perché ha
preso preso esatto ma per il gioco no e
c'è un altro modo per uccidere che le
spie madonna che quello di andare vicini
e picchiare però non c'è un motivo
perché lei potrebbero essere girarsi e
morire io senza un motivo
ma come quello più picchiare non lo so
sto non lo so questo quinto episodio che
faccio non ho ancora capito niente di
questo gioco sono i pallini non lo so
qualora aveva verso le alfa l'esperto ma
io non so dirti allora questo gioco a
tre meccaniche e io di queste tre ne so
una questo gioco non si vince in base a
quanto si partecipa
no esatto ma non si aspetti che lo
voglio beccarli ma che bravo ajax le
dicevo queste gioco è bellissimo perché
non si ascolti qua perché un casino
aperte però si vince in base a quante
volte uno mette ko l'altro ce la faccio
fuori in serata dei tre ma non è detto
che vinca rv gale quindi ero
spettacolarità che mi e la
spettacolarità
non lo so non lo so non ho ancora capito
in base a che cosa
però non è in base a quante volte la
butta la butto giù mi butta giù lei
cazzo che dolore
questa l'ho sentita una forse quelle i
pallini gialli sono rocce provi a
lanciare quella vediamo orpello bilancio
ma ciò via ecco così no sono le noci
avvalora certo ho capito mi scusi sono
veloci rimanenti ho capito che non c'è
per rimanere però non ho capito il
punteggio in base a cosa in base a
quanto si butta giù una persona vi ho
già un 3 io auto all 80 i giorni butti
giù ma ammirare un incubo paletta ai a
liam è ok e lei ha detto che in questo 5
per tempo per professori né debito
aspetti aspetti aspetti cielo
adesso capisco la testa nome nato 6 e no
ma sono sei adesso in tutto come 6 vedi
che è difficilissimo da capire non si
preoccupi il suo primato di uscire
vogliono 5 ha previsto 7 se io adesso
sono otto e non ci sono più rocce però
ero appunto rende ci picchiamo e non
sono mai arrivate alla sudan in tutto
straw periodo il corto in gol attenzione
e siamo morti tutti e due o combat
terminato meno 6
quindi è no io sono uscito sbagliare
però non è capace gli atoms fa capace
pronto
le faccio mangiare la polvere dove che
lei
eccolo una figura da ciò di tutti e due
ma come adesso mi ha dato tre pro
adesso mi ha dato tre senza motivo
credit ma come combattermi nato perché
questo successo non lo so non mi è mai
successa questa cosa
questo gioco non si capisce che poi non
c'è tanto da capire però non si capisce
lo stesso mi scusi aia e vabbè ho vinto
ero io eh sì ai altro
sono risposato e vecchi questo che poi è
difficile tirare il sasso da dietro è
veramente un duro pur che ti dice anche
dove lo sta lanciando che scrive come
combattermi nato ma perché è con due
sole botte
lei dovrebbe trovare qualcosa di meglio
da fare devo vedere dice perché se
questo nelle renale 2 grazie al fenomeno
non va secondo me il mio tempo impiegato
in modo ricco e sostanzioso
poi non so lei le minime tornati qui
effettivamente non è proprio educativo
come gioco persino bisognerebbe mai
lanciare dei sassi contro le può
diventare così grassi e anche quello che
potrebbe essere un problema però aspetti
no credo che questa roccia bianca se
tipo il sette bello cioè nel senso se
colpisce con quella vale di più per
qualche strano motivo la mi piace non
raccolgo niente aia a lei tanto sono
riuscito a cadere nell unica di una che
esisteva ma lei anna anaya no ecco lì
aveva preso tantissimo qua e che è
brutto che brutto lancio fatto io
mannaggia notte in un punto che non lo
so neanche io mi scusi qualcuno sta
parlando in casa mia sembra una zanzara
il bianco l'asso pigliatutto io ho
provate e può essere preso subito
colleghiamo per sfatare questo però qui
a chi ce lo cambiano parole è un altro
bianco quello e vede quindi gente si
effettivamente da ciò abbiamo scoperto
una regola di questo gioco che non
sapevo neanche io fantastico la palla 8
qui la palla 8 e il bianco ok va bene
aiuto che cari seria adesso si gioca
solo per vincere
mi ha colpito è quello di fermo sei
riuscito neanche a raccoglierla no te
che cazzo a lei no no jean louis scherz
eccolo che ansia mamma mia
a lei madonna si sprecano tutto il
bianco sempre dove dovrete metto dove
l'ha lanciato mia persona nello del
potere chi oddio sia fermo iphone e io
no mega qua in realtà una tattica che ho
che ho scoperto e rimanere tanto vicini
perché si rimane tanto vicino cappuccino
riesco a non riesce a che non riesci a
colpirmi
no sono stupido venga qua ma vado ne
vale proprio tutto tutto
eh si non mi preme e non ci posso
credere noto ieri il new come mai
ecco che sono molto vicino ho capito
teoricamente io dovrei e core grazie
però se il gran partita di reni fare di
fare ancora una così a bari questo
proprio gran gioco comunque io consiglio
l'acquisto e free to play no però dico
anche i 10 euro per l'espansione e mai
nessuno di noi due lo ha fatto non vedo
l'ora di vedere come tra l'altro lo
farei solo per cui i traguardi per lo
deve fare è un grande youtuber e lo farò
se mi 75 bene il popolo mio grazie aiuto
no ai ha rischiato tantissimo venga
d'olio lì perché l'animazione è uno il
team investito da un tir
esatto
no che brutta cosa no ma dai mega qua
come mai è successo aiuto perché lo
aveva detto che culo mi fa sempre dire
che lei si tiene proprio
all'apprezzamento del mouse ma dai ma
perché lì ma no non l'ho beccata non so
perché mi hanno fregato e stato molto
bello vero per me va bene così
l'ultimissima perché la bella o basta
no io mi fermerei mi fermerei co anche
io signori ha vinto chi ha vinto ha
vinto lo sporco come sempre non si
capisce una sega ha visto gioco però
ringrazio il gatto per essersi prestato
a questo gameplay di gioco particolare
diventa i nemici lasciate mi piace è
passato anche dal gatto e schiacciate la
campanellina e fatte tutte queste cose
che sono noiose da fare ma sono giuste e
quindi voi lo farete perchè noi abbia
passato due ore attirarci le pietre con
due ciccioni ma che ci vediamo al
prossimo video la ragazza
[Musica]